Donald Trump has fallen to the number  three most likely guy to win the  presidency in 2024 according to the  betting markets this is according to  people who put their money where  everyone's mouth is and who are staking  real cash on who is going to win Trump  is in third place he's got a 20 chance  of returning to the White House with  four to one odds Joe Biden has a 22.2  percent chance of being reelected in two  years on seven to two odds Ron DeSantis  they the Vegas betting markets are  giving him 30.8 percent seven to two  odds  to win the White House so right now Ron  DeSantis is leading the pack and and  people have to take this seriously I  Know That No One Believes any polls  especially two years out from a  presidential election but we're just  seeing all the signs move into Santos's  Direction